this morning on the dish a chef and
restaurateur who was getting recognition
not just for his food but for who is
serving its Brandon Christos key
received the silver plate award this
month and honored he now shares with
Wolfgang Puck Danny Meyer and others but
Christakis operation is a little
different his kitchens are staffed by
ex-cons and he's made it his mission to
give others the second chance in life he
says he was granted years ago we visited
with him last summer
who's that burger tonight guys and
edwin's restaurant in Cleveland you can
start rocking the only thing more
important than turning out the finest
food and wine is turning around the
lives of its employees did you order
your I take a look and see what you
branded Christos key is the man in
charge sit back enjoy two decades ago he
was a boy in trouble you were dealing
drugs mm-hmm how old 18 what happened
well we got caught up in a little thing
and police came we all left he took off
took off Christos he found himself in
front of a forgiving judge the charge
that carry was about five ten years in
prison
why didn't he do that well I think
there's two reasons color of my skin and
the grace of God given probation instead
of hard time Christoph's key caught on
inside a kitchen in his hometown of
Detroit trained at the Culinary
Institute of America and was soon
working at top French restaurants in
Paris and New York but the second chance
he got was always in the back of his
mind so he came up with a plan the goal
is to have the best French restaurants
in the world the best French restaurant
in the world in Cleveland yeah
Ohio why here I just looked at where the
worst high school graduation rate was in
Cleveland Ohio happened to be the number
two city in the country where people in
high school didn't graduate so I figure
that's the place that it's needed you
went to where you saw the situation
being the worst and said I'm gonna make
the best make sense one time like this
like this everyone who trains at Edwin's
short for education wins has had some
sort of run-in with the law and then he
spent years in prison it's a restaurant
it's the school it's the the Institute
yeah Chris dusky wants to redirect their
lives with a restaurant bootcamp a
six-month program that provides housing
a library donated clothes even a small
farm students take classes on a wide
range of topics including the art of
champagne tasting and opening twist the
cork one way the bottle the other the
days are long noon until midnight and
only 30% of students make it through
when you talk to someone either in
prison or just out of prison and you
tell them that you want to train them to
become a French chef what's the usual
reaction I think it's twofold I think
it's one I have no idea what you're
talking about I can't say that on TV
yeah I have no idea what you're talking
about and the other thing is if you give
me sand I'll drink it just give me an
opportunity I'll take it because that
opportunity hasn't been there in the
past what's your goal long-term change
of face really change the face before
you change the face you're going to
change that perception of someone coming
out of prison or jail or a bad hard time
or addiction you're not a lost soul
you're you're redeemable of course yeah
of course malar edema you were a diamond
and kick some ass too so now we're
getting to something little bit more
intimate that's fish all right I mean
it's me of all the things to cook I have
two passions of cooking I mean cooking
in general but risotto and fish Christos
Key also trains those still doing time
inside 13 ohio prisons including here at
Grafton Correctional Institution these
men will be out soon
no one wants them to reoffending there
on the bone man you guys did a great job
Chris Chomsky says they need skills the
class we watched is full of hardcore
convicts you're too forceful if you got
to push that higher you're doing so
you're cutting through bone sentences
for murder
kidnapping armed robbery and more let's
find that sharpest blade steal it and
we'll go to town today they're learning
to filet salmon you've got guys who have
been convicted of some pretty horrendous
crimes with large very sharp knives that
concern you at all no good this is the
most FPS I feel all week it's really the
safest place and you can never be inside
a prison with inmates with sharp knives
it's the safest place you can be you
know focused and dedicated their life to
to call any arts to improving to
fulfilling potential there's no greater
space to be in with another human being
dear Olympic is nearing the end of a
decade-long sentence for drug
trafficking and weapons charges you know
what they say right you get out what you
put in so I guess you put into work you
reap the reward are you ready to put in
the work in the right in the right way
for sure I've had enough definitely had
enough nine years
I can walk the strainer I can do the
rest and you think these classes help
you gives me a purpose Christophe skis
non profit program is funded by his main
restaurants and private donations he
says he won't take any government money
what do you want people to take from the
idea of
Edwin's well it is hope this thing is
supported by like 7 year olds who've
given up four dollars their allowance
four dollars and a ziploc bag of coin
and the next day it's a half million
dollar check so from the very least of
us to the very most of us it works and
without that it doesn't work so the hero
here is a community the community of
people staffing this the community
people supported it
seven-year-old you can't say that on TV
[Laughter]
it is yes seven years old she believes
that someone is there's a second chance
right so a couple updates here first
that Brandon won the silver plate away
which we congratulate him on well
well-deserved also he's now running
during the coronavirus he's running a
virtual program so people can keep
learning because they're not showing up
in the restaurant right they want to
keep learning about food in the process
and it's so important to give people a
purpose as he said another opportunity
to think about a time like this even
more important you don't want to see a
business like this not being able to
continue and it's in an industry that
obviously is so hard two amazing quotes
from Brandon one was in the piece
they're about opportunity if you give me
sand I'll drink it because that
opportunity wasn't there before the
other one that he's saying now is when
you have time which so many people do
when you have time you have dreams